your surgeon will perform an aortic
valve replacement if your aortic valve
is not functioning properly the heart is
a muscular organ that pumps blood
through the body
it consists of four chambers the upper
chambers are the right and left atria
the lower chambers are the right and
left ventricles the right and left atria
connect to their respective ventricles
the right ventricle connects to the
pulmonary artery and the left ventricle
to the aorta valves are located at these
connections to ensure that blood moves
in only one direction the parts of a
valve that open and close are flaps of
tissue called cusps the aortic valve is
located between the left ventricle and
the aorta when the heart contracts the
aortic valve opens and blood is pumped
into the aorta when the heart relaxes it
closes to prevent blood from leaking
back into the left ventricle a normal
aortic valve has three smooth cusps that
open widely and close tightly your
aortic valve may be leaky or narrowed
causing your heart to work harder and
disrupt your blood flow a leaky valve
does not close all the way causing blood
to leak back into the ventricle between
each heartbeat this condition is called
aortic regurgitation a narrowed aortic
valve does not open all the way which
restricts the amount of blood passing
out of the ventricle into the aorta this
condition is called aortic stenosis you
may have been born with an abnormal a or
take valve for example your aortic valve
may only have two cusps instead of three
so it may not open and close properly
your aorta
valve may have become damaged during
your lifetime a condition called
acquired a or Tec valve disease causes
include romatic fever which can be a
complication of untreated strep throat
endocarditis which is a bacterial
infection of the valve and sclerosis or
hardening of the aortic leafless after a
period of time a faulty aortic valve can
cause the heart muscles to become
enlarged and weakened depending on the
nature of the valves defect the walls of
the left ventricle may become abnormally
thick or thin and the problem can
eventually affect the right side of the
heart as well patients with this
condition known as heart failure may
experience shortness of breath chest
pain or angina pectoris dizziness
lightheadedness and or fainting swelling
of the ankles feet and legs and fatigue
and a or Tek valve replacement is
performed to restore the valve to normal
function
before your procedure an IV line will be
started in your arm to provide fluids
and medications a catheter will be
inserted into your bladder to drain
urine a or tech valve replacements are
done under general anesthesia this means
you will be asleep for the duration of
the operation and a tube will be placed
through your mouth and into your
windpipe to help you breathe during
surgery
once the anesthesia takes effect your
surgeon will begin by making an incision
in the chest the traditional incision is
made in the middle of the chest
overlying the breastbone or sternum the
surgeon then separates the sternum to
expose the pericardium which is a
protective membrane encircling the heart
your surgeon will then open the
pericardium to expose the heart at this
point your heart will be connected to a
heart-lung machine tubes are used to
reroute your blood into this machine
which takes over the functions of the
heart and lungs during the operation
once the heart-lung machine has taken
over your heart will be temporarily
stopped and the blood inside removed
this keeps the aortic valve still and
allows your surgeon to see it your
surgeon will open the aorta to expose
the aortic valve make an incision around
the edge of the damaged valve and remove
it your surgeon will then carefully so
the replacement valve into place and
close the aorta with stitches at this
point blood will again be allowed to
flow into your heart to check the
function of the new valve if needed an
electric shock will be given to restart
the heart once your heart is beating on
its own it will be detached from the
heart-lung machine generally temporary
pacemaker wires will be placed on the
surface of the heart to ensure the heart
maintains a normal rhythm during
recovery
after surgery you'll be taken to the
intensive care unit where your vital
functions will be monitored you will
still have a breathing tube in your
throat which will prevent you from
talking several tubes will be in place
to drain blood and fluid from your
incision and your bladder catheter will
still be draining your urine